We are just beginning
to understand that loss
of grouper and parrot
fish has a domino effect,
and kills the reef.
It's happening so fast, it
doesn't take an old-timer
to remember the good old days.
In just my short
lifetime of 19 years,
been able to see immense
change in at least the one
habitat that I've been able
to dive on since I was four
with my dad.
[music playing]
The way I remember it is this
absolutely magical place,
these immaculate reefs,
such vibrant color no matter
where you went, a
treasure trove of fish
and incredible ecosystem.
But now, going back
the last three years,
it looks like a pile of
rubble after a building was
demolished in New York City.
It's all gray and
white and crumbled,
and the fish are gone.
And that's only in--
And that's just in
the United States.
In 12 years, yeah.
[music playing]
The waters around
Buck Island are an oasis
in a fast-expanding
wasteland fueled by climate
change and overfishing.
I would love to have seen
what you saw here as a boy.
The fish population
was very diverse,
very large, very colorful.
But you know, even my benchmark
was nothing in comparison
to my father's benchmark.
You went, ah!
You should have seen
it when I was a boy.
You know, these are
small fish compared
to when he was growing up.
The corals need the fish,
the fish need the corals.
You take the fish away,
the corals are stressed.
Expanding the refuge to
embrace the devastated reefs
outside of the monument will
give the natural systems
a chance to recover.
People say I came
from a different planet.
I did.
The planet was so
different when I arrived.
[music playing]
90% Of the big fish
are already gone,
but the great news is
we can turn the corner.
We can restore.
[music playing]